the washington football team shireen
will have an opportunity to boost their
record from last year
seven and nine two eight nine and i'm
telling you
let me let me press pause on what we're
about to play as it relates to ron
rivera's
session with the media yesterday i'm
gonna have a hell of a time getting used
to this concept of
eight nine seven and ten eleven and
six i mean we've got 16 games
baked in and i remember it was a tough
adjustment
going from seven and seven eight and six
nine and five
ten and four back in 1978 but
i'd only been following the nfl for five
years then this has been 44 years of
16 games this is just it sounds weird
and it feels wrong
to hear these these one loss records
premised on 17. yeah and
let's remember tooth mike a team can go
eight eight and one
so it's still possible that a team could
finish at 500 but it's a little more
complicated to get there
obviously but simple things mike i was
putting up a post last night about jason
verrette right how many games he had
missed so i was trying to do
all the possible games he could have
played so it took seven seasons times
16.
and i'm thinking about to myself as i'm
doing this well this is
gonna change after this year you're
gonna have to go okay
how many possible games could he play
like wait how many seasons were 17 games
how many
seasons were 16 games so a lot of things
might get more complicated with 17 games
from
our standpoint for sure and the one
point that we made the other day when we
drafted the potential rule
changes not rule changes but the
potential i'm looking down at the
at my sheet when i should be thinking
the potential
records that could be broken by 17
games you you're gonna have somebody
play 18 games because there have been
guys who played 17 because they were
traded
before their current team had a buy to a
team that's already had a buy
you end up playing 17 games most
recently emanuel sanders did that
in 2019 when he went from denver to san
francisco all right
back to washington the team that was
seven and nine and maybe will be eight
and nine this year or eight eight and
one who knows ron rivera
talking about his quarterback situation
and specifically the
urgency to have what they don't
currently have a quarterback of the
future
and how do you feel about the concept of
the quarterback of the future you need
your quote-unquote quarterback of the
future
is that a pressure to define that now
this year
no no no and i say that just because of
the fact that
if you put all the other pieces in the
place
and and now you start going forward when
that guy does show up
when that guy is in the right position
you can grab him
i went through it the other way my first
stint as a head coach in carolina we
drafted the quarterback of the future
for us
in the first round uh and he was lo and
behold the immediate future
i've always thought wow you know if if
you could
do it the other way where you put all
the other pieces around and then go out
and get your quarterback
man that might be a pretty good
situation too a lot of teams
did that i've seen a lot of teams that
have have have had
things in place and then drafted their
quarterback the next year
um this could be one of these situations
where we
put all the other pieces in place and a
year or two from now the right guy's
there and we can make that move
but we'll see i mean again you just
never really know
until you get there three types of teams
in the nfl shireen teams that have long
term franchise quarterbacks teams that
are searching for one
and teams that have a guy that they're
not quite sure whether or not he's going
to become one
washington falls into category two
because they don't have one
and they need to be desperately
searching for one the problem is this
year
they're not going to get one it's not
going to happen they're not going to
trade
for deshaun watson they're not going to
trade for russell wilson
they are going to tread water with ryan
fitzpatrick
taylor heinecke and ryan allen there's
too many of these quarterbacks last name
allen kyle allen ryan allen kyle allen
they know who we mean
alan kyle quarterback
that doesn't matter to me at all these
backup quarterbacks where you can flip
their last name in their first name and
it still sounds like a real guy
kyle allen taylor heineke ryan
fitzpatrick
none of them franchise quarterbacks but
last year they got to the playoffs
without a franchise quarterback and
they're just gonna have to
keep searching and hoping and waiting
that they find a guy
who will be their answer for the next 10
or 15 years or given the way these
quarterbacks are playing now a day's
even longer than that
yeah you know mike what's amazing is
this is lowest
washington has picked since 2016 so
you're
you're thinking if they've picked that
high why don't they have one of these
guys why don't they have their franchise
quarterback well
it's obvious right they drafted the
wrong guy dwayne haskins was their
choice to be their franchise quarterback
it didn't work out it was quickly over
the haskins era in washington ended very
very fast
so they're back at the drawing board to
figure out who that guy's going to be
now i still think they could do what
philadelphia did last year right they
drafted jalen hurts in the second round
there's going to be a kellen monde or
one of those guys sitting there it late
in the first round or in the second
round that they could draft and if they
like that guy
you draft him and see what you have in
him let him groom under ryan fitzpatrick
for a season hey ryan fitzpatrick is
used to doing this
he did it last year in miami and was
replaced by tua so
there is a possibility they could end up
with one but they're certainly not going
to get one of the top guys mike there's
no way
not the way it's been shaking out as
more and more of these top guys are
clustering toward
the top ten ryan fitzpatrick will have
competition
rivera said and that's good look i love
ryan fitzpatrick great for the game
great for the sport
great story if you haven't heard he went
to harvard that's news to me
but he does have the propensity when you
finally believe in him
to implode and implode in a spectacular
way to the point where he gets benched
and then when he gets a chance to come
back he's better than he was before
by far so he's not a guy that's going to
take you to the super bowl he's a guy
that could take you
to the nfc east championship which is a
low bar right now
but when washington becomes a super bowl
contender
it will be with a franchise quarterback
and i think that's part of what ron
rivera is trying to build
moving in the direction where you're
putting the rest of the infrastructure
in place
so that when you do add a franchise
quarterback
from wherever you may find him whether
it's a rookie
who you draft or a veteran
who falls into your lap via trade via
tom brady style hey look i can go
anywhere i want
wow washington's got a pretty good team
all they need is a quarterback so
you just need to get the pieces in place
and then when the opportunity arises you
need to move to get the franchise
quarterback and the one thing that they
need to do is
keep daniel schneider locked in a closet
somewhere so he doesn't force them to
reach
for a guy who really isn't ready to come
in and be anyone's franchise quarterback
which they did two years ago with dwayne
haskins even though dwayne haskins still
would have been a first round pick i
believe
15 ultimately was too high and also we
can't blame it all on haskins
we've seen time it again no matter how
good the quarterback you put him in a
bad spot
and and he he's gonna fail
and and i think there's a chance that's
part of what happened here that's what
makes
haskins arrival in pittsburgh
interesting because maybe pittsburgh
can turn him into the guy who was taking
15th overall
yeah his stay in in pittsburgh will be
very interesting obviously with ben
roethlisberger probably in
in his final season mike but you know
back to washington i think they've done
the right thing here with ryan
fitzpatrick you didn't get matthew
stafford he was your first choice right
and we all know they tried to get in on
that trade and and couldn't make it
happen
deshaun watts is going to be traded at
some point and perhaps for
much less than what he originally was
going to go for
so maybe washington at some point ends
up with desean watson as her quarterback
i don't know that it's going to happen
before the season starts maybe at the
trade deadline maybe after this season
but i still think that could be a
possibility for washington to end up
with desean watson
as their quarterback but for now it's
ryan fitzpatrick and i think this is a
great move for washington
because he can be that bridge guy we've
seen it right
but there is a reason that he's moved
around there's a reason he's with his
ninth team
and learning his ninth playbook and
there's also a reason why he's in his
16th season his throne
passes the 61 different receivers so
he's been good enough to hang around
this league
start a whole bunch of games but not
good enough to stick with one team
and i did a little research last night
mike looking at who
all replaced him because you think he
would have stayed somewhere for
longer than what he did but it's it's
not even a very good list of guys who've
replaced them it's ej manuel
zach metzenberger brian hoyer josh
mccowan and then of course tua last year
are some of the guys who've replaced
them uh in these different spots where
he's been so it's kind of interesting
that uh
he's been not been replaced by any real
franchise guy
in the past other than tua who the
jury's still out on whether he is that
franchise guy
yeah his star really shown the brightest
a decade ago
when he got a big contract in buffalo
and they thought he was the answer and
they quickly realized
he wasn't i mean that that's that's the
you got to use fits in limited doses
and brian flores the dolphins coach had
figured out last year
when to get him in the game when to get
him out of the game get him out before
fitzmagic becomes fits tragic and put
him back in
and let him work his magic like he did
most recently in that
saturday night game against the las
vegas raiders when it was just
spectacular and we've seen spectacular
from him enough
to expect amounts of it but we've seen
the opposite spectacular enough to
to know that you better have somebody
else and if it's patrick is the week one
starter
there's a pretty good chance he gets
benched at some point for
kyle allen or alan kyle or heineke
taylor
one of those three or four guys may have
a chance to play it plus as you pointed
out
the ever present possibility that desean
watson ends up being
traded to washington on a bargain
basement rate the one thing we
didn't know before the ugliness of the
last 17 days first emerged for deshaun
watts and we still don't know now we
don't know where he's willing to play
that's the one thing we didn't get from
him we got it from russell wilson
we never got it from desean watson not
with any kind of clarity not with the
agent going on the record to say
here are the teams hypothetically to
which desean watson would accept a trade
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports